Today we are going to be talking about a problem in logic
and how in solving that problem,
Alan Turing almost inadvertently
invented the modern digital computer.
So we start back at the beginning of the
20th century, where mathematicians had
posed this problem - in logic we're
interested in finding "Do these premises
entail this conclusion?" So premises are
the bits you start off with in an argument
they are your -- the bits you know at the
beginning or your assumptions and the
conclusion is the bit you want to
establish the bit that you reason to
with your argument and we want to know
is there a test that will tell us
yes for sure these premises do or don't
entail this conclusion. Is there an
automatic way of finding out whether
they do or whether they don't?
So that's the problem, it's called the
decision problem.
The mathematicians wanted to find out "Is
there an answer to the decision problem
for first order logic?"
that's the kind of logic you learn in
philosophy or mathematics at university
so lots of mathematicians were trying to
work out is first order logic decidable
that is can we automatically test
whether the premises entail the
conclusion
Alan Turing was one of the first to
discover that first order logic isn't
decidable. To prove this
it's really difficult conceptually
because you have to be able to show no
possible program can give you the answer
but how do you do that how do you show
something about every possible program
you can't run through every program one
by one
but Turing came up with a brilliant
solution
his idea goes something like this
suppose we have a program and let's just
draw it as a black box
it's going to take some inputs and it's
going to give us some outputs
our program is going to solve some
problem a problem like "Do the premises
entail the conclusion" we ask it a
question and it will give us an answer
yes or no
now here's another question we can ask
let's look at all of those possible
programs and we're just thinking of them
as black boxes at the moment we might
want to know is this program given a
certain input going to give us an answer
or is it going to trundle on forever and
never give us an answer that is is it
going to halt or is it not going to halt
eventually so think about your computer
running you want it to give you an
answer of whether it's a good answer or
a bad answer
it's better than no answer. No answer
would mean the computer trundles around
forever and ever in a loop and you would
just never know whether it's going to
finish today tomorrow or never
so halting is good so there's another
question we can ask given some program
and some input
will it ever halt? Now it turns out that
our logical problem
"Do these premises entail this conclusion?"
is very similar to this halting problem
in fact if we can solve the logical
problem then we can solve the halting
problem
will this program halt on this input so
the clever part of Turing's proof is
to show that it's impossible for any
machine however clever it is to solve
the halting problem that is to tell us
whether a given machine with a given
input will halt or not - and here's how
he did it
let's suppose we've got a machine or a
program that solves the problem for us
it solves the halting problem don't
worry about how it works let's just
think of it as a black box taking the
description of a machine and an input
and giving us an answer
yes it will halt or no it won't halt
just suppose that's possible
call that machine "h" for the halting
problem - if you give me that machine
I can transform it into a different
machine like this
I stick some extra bits on it so that if
it gives me a yes answer
I make it loop forever without ever
stopping
if it gives me a no answer on the other
hand
and it's going to halt straight away
let's call that big machine
the whole thing "h+" now here's another
question we can ask what happens if I
feed the whole machine into itself so
i'm going to put h+ in here and h+
in here
so the question I'm now asking is I'm
feeding h+ into itself so i'm asking the
question "Does h+ halt given input h+?"
and here's where it all goes wrong
because if h plus does halt
we get a yes answer but then it loops
forever
so it doesn't halt on the other hand if
it doesn't halt
we get a no answer but then it halts so
if it does halt then it doesn't halt
but if it doesn't halt then it does
halt. Either way we get a contradiction
it's a paradox but what that shows is we
started off assuming that we can solve
the problem
we've ended up with a paradox so our
assumption was bad
it turns out there's no possible machine
no possible program that solves the
halting problem
the really clever bit about Turing's
idea is it doesn't matter what kind of
program our machine is. It doesn't matter
whether it's an abstract algorithm
whether it's a real computer, a physical
computer
it doesn't matter what it is we've prove
that no such program as possible
Turing as part of his argument had to
say a little bit about what's going on
in these black boxes //DFB: and the idea is
that every card represents an instruction
in the Turing machine